[موسيقى]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون
القمر فاذا سمع الجمالين الجمال الكوني
القمر وجمال النجوم الثريا قال العامه
هالقمر جارنا ثريا فالمقارنه معناها
الاستماع ولهذا سمي عقد النكاح بعقد قران
لانه جمع بين اثنين من الاصل لانهما
مفترقين فاذا وقع القمر بجانب الثريا يوم
الحادي عشر من الشهر الهجري قال العامه
قران عادي
فهو اماره علامه على بدايه البرد كحالي
ايامنا هذه انت القمر والشمس والارض
والكون وانت السماء وانت النجوم الرفيعه
وانت الذهب والماس غالي ومكنون يا دره
الخسران
من هو يبيعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فالقمر يدور حول الكره الارضيه 12 مره
بسنه ويلتقي بثريا في كل شهر مره بمعنى
انه يلتقي به 12 مره هذا بس انا سته منها
لقيا نهاريه غير مهمات وستا منها لقيا
ليليه وهذه المهمات فاهم الاقترانات سته
اثنين منها شتوي واثنين منها ربيعي واثنين
منها صيفي فاقتران الشهر هذا قران عادي
وشهر الجاي
اللاسع والشهر اللي بعده جراند سابع مجيع
وشابع اذا لم ازر الا لي اكلي اكله فما
رفعت كفي الي طعامي فما اكلاتها بغنيمه
ولا جوعها
بغرامي
[موسيقى]